MILENA NIKOLIC: Hi,
we're here to talk to you
about how we are rethinking app
distribution on Google Play.
We'll talk about the new app
publishing format, the Android
bundle, which we've
launched with I/O year
and all the features we've built
since kind of in this area.
But to start with, let's
talk about the app size,
why does the app
size even matter?
KOBI GLICK: So you all know
that app size is important.
We shared with you this
chart earlier this year
at Google I/O. According
to play store data,
as app size gets bigger, there
install success rate goes down.
Users don't have enough storage,
especially in emerging markets
where the connections are
slow, the data is expensive.
And I want you to think about
your own experience too.
How many of you have
seen this message
by Google Play asking
you to uninstall apps
to make space for more installs?
Millions of users
see that every day.
We started to look into
this more closely recently,
and we found out that
clearing up space
is a major driver of uninstalls.
And this is obviously a
problem for entry level devices
in emerging markets,
but it's also
a problem for users who fill up
their devices with HD content.
Take the US and the UK, for
example, one in five users
are getting to the
point that they run out
of space in which they can't
really install or update
anymore.
MILENA NIKOLIC: A key request
we've heard from developers
is also for help understanding
and reducing on installs.
We ran a user research study
with our users in the US
about the reasons why
they uninstall apps.
And what we've
heard as the leading
reasons why users uninstall
within the first day
is quality.
Quality is something
we do care a lot.
And as Thomson has said,
we have a separate Android
vital session later
where we can tell you
all about how to improve
the performance of your app.
However, the leading reasons
why users uninstall the apps
after it's been on
the device for a month
is to save up space.
So what this shows
you is that there
are two big reasons
why you should care
about the size of your app.
Bigger apps lose acquisitions,
and bigger apps also
get uninstalled more often.
I think many of you are, kind
of, already aware of this.
So you would think that everyone
would be doing everything
in their power to reduce
the size of their app.
And yet, apps and games
keep getting better.
Over the last five years,
the size of the app
has effectively
went five times--
it's five times
larger on average.
Newer devices have more
storage, but apps and games
and HD videos and high res
photos, all of those things
are getting larger too.
Now, there are also some
very good reasons why
the apps are getting bigger.
Kobi, tell us more about it.
KOBI GLICK: So the first
reason is that you simply
keep adding awesome features
and services to your app,
and you come up with new
ideas and you take advantage
of device capabilities.
But with every new
feature, you obviously
increase the app size.
And Android has these
amazing diversity.
There are thousands of
devices to choose from,
and you want your apps and
games to run beautifully
on all those devices.
So many developers add
all those resources
in their APKs to support
architectures and screen
densities and languages.
And when you add all
of these resources,
you increase the
size of your app.
So we've seen two main reasons
why apps keep getting bigger.
You add awesome
features, and you
add resources to support all
the Android devices out there.
But we've also seen that
increasing the app size
comes with downsides.
And I'm sure some of
you have considered
the following trade-off before.
Do I keep on adding features and
resources so my app runs really
well on all those devices,
but I lose installs
and drive more on
uninstalls along the way?
This is a pretty bad trade-off.
We don't want you to be making
those kind of trade-offs.
MILENA NIKOLIC: So
there is a current way
to optimize your app
for different device
configurations.
We call it multiple APKs, but
it's, kind of, inefficient
and, frankly, we think
it can be quite tedious.
This is what it looks like
in the Play Console when
you have to upload dozens of
APKs for each of your releases.
The number of APKs
can grow quite quickly
with different dimensions,
for example, 64-bit
versus 32-bit, smaller screens,
larger screens, and so on.
And then on top of that,
you have to version
each APK individually,
which kind of adds
to the complexity about this.
It also doesn't help with
all of the dimensions.
For example, for
languages you still need
to include all languages
in each one of your APKs.
So multi-APK is not a solution.
It's not great.
We know we can do better.
Let's look at the actual
solution we've built for this
and how the new app model
helps make your life easier
in this area.
New app model is focused on
improving the entire user
acquisition journey from
discovery through to retention.
It helps by making your
app smaller, and as such
kind of improving both your
install and uninstall rate.
And in addition to
that, it makes managing
your releases much easier.
KOBI GLICK: In this
session, we are
going to talk about four steps
in user acquisition journey we
want to help you with.
First, we want to help you with
discovery by allowing users
to try your apps.
Then we want to help you
convert users to installers.
Next, we want to allow
you to deliver features
and functionality on demand
to different audiences when
they need it.
And finally, we want
to help you retain
your users with the latest and
greatest version of your app.
We're going to
start by how we help
you make your installs smaller.
This is the first step in
your journey as a developer,
and this is where we made a
big announcement at Google I/O
with the Android app bundle.
We are going to talk about the
other steps in user acquisition
journey later in this talk.
MILENA NIKOLIC: So
here is the big idea.
Google Play can
assist and take care
of delivering only
what is needed
to each device on your behalf.
There is no need to send bunch
of free sources or languages
to users devices if they're
not going to need them.
We support three
slicing dimensions out
of the box, CPU
architectures, languages,
and screen densities.
To take advantage of this, start
building with a new publishing
format, the Android app bundle.
The size reduction
varies, but on average we
are seeing 35% size savings
compared to universal APK.
This is huge.
So with the bundle, you get
resource slicing for free,
and you're also on the road
to using dynamic features
and offering instant
experiences both of which
we'll talk about later.
And we've been chatting a
lot to developers like you
about what is the thing they
like about the bundle most.
Recently, we did a workshop
with some developers
in India who make some of the
most popular apps over there.
Riafy, redBus, and Swiggy.
These developers have
millions of installs,
and they're very
sophisticated in keeping
the size of their app small
because their users are
very sensitive to it.
Riafy found that
smaller installs
improved their conversion rate.
RedBus found that releases were
streamlined and much easier
to manage.
And Swiggy found that
switching was a simple process,
and they were able
to start testing
with the bundle within an hour.
KOBI GLICK: And it's not
just developers in India.
As you can see here,
developers all around the world
are switching and are seeing
fantastic size savings.
For example, Duolingo
saw 56% size savings
compared to universal APK.
This huge savings
is very difficult
to achieve with only
incremental optimization.
So switching to the app bundle
is the single most impactful
thing developers can do to
reduce the size of their app,
and Google Apps are
switching as well.
YouTube, Google
Maps, and Google News
are all today in production
with Android app bundles.
So as you can see, this
is not experimental.
This is ready.
We have thousands of
bundles in production today.
It's time for all developers
to switch to the new publishing
format.
MILENA NIKOLIC: As
a matter of fact,
we've just crossed
10,000 overnight tonight.
KOBI GLICK: Yesterday.
In Android Studio 3.2, which
is now stable and available
to all developers,
you can build bundles.
It's very similar
to building an APK,
so the switch is pretty
straightforward for most
developers.
And in the Play Console,
we're starting to show you
this very colorful chart.
When we think you could benefit
from moving to the bundle,
we'll take a common
reference device
and we'll calculate
how much you save
comparing to a universal APK.
MILENA NIKOLIC: And
we're excited to share
that games using Unity can now
start building the bundle too.
Unity added support
for our bundles
in the 2018 3 beta
release, and you
can join this beta right now.
OK, so I think many of you have
heard about all this already,
but let me explain
how it actually works.
The way it works is you
put everything related
to your app in the bundle,
Play processes the bundle
and generates these
optimize APKs.
We sign the APKs and
deliver each signed APK
to each individual user device.
This means that
the new app model
requires you to upload your
signing key to Google Play.
And again in conversations
I've had with developers
like yourselves, sometimes I've
heard the question of, like,
is this secure?
And the answer is absolutely.
Rest assured that we take
this very, very seriously.
We protect your keys
in the same storage
that we protect Google's
own signing keys.
We have a large team of
engineers focused entirely
on security, and
you will benefit
from our ongoing
investments in this area.
And the reason this
step is so critical
is because when we
have the signing key,
we can optimize the app
that we deliver to devices
on an ongoing basis without
your continuous work
and improvements.
Kobi, do you want to share
one of those examples?
KOBI GLICK: Sure.
So because Google Play
does the processing,
we can introduce those
kind of optimizations
without asking you to
put any time and effort.
So we just launched a new
optimization for developers
to upload app bundles
for an Android OS feature
that was introduced
in Android M called
uncompressed native libraries.
Before Android M, you need
to provide native libraries
compressed and the
OS uncompresses them
so it installs two
copies on the device.
After Android M, you can
provide your native libraries
uncompressed and the OS
only installs a single copy
saving a lot of space.
Now because Google Play
does the processing,
we can do it for you.
But if we haven't, you actually
need to fork your app for pre-M
and post M with multi-APK,
which is pretty painful.
And who would want
to do that, right?
So we're doing it for you.
If you're using the
app bundle, you just
give us your native libraries
compressed or uncompressed.
We create the different
flavors for pre-M and post
M saving users a lot
of space on the device.
The numbers you see
here, for example,
are for a Gameloft
game, My Little Pony.
These numbers are on top of
the numbers they actually
got from switching to the
bundle in the first place.
The numbers we're seeing on
average across the entire app
corpus are still
very significant,
8% reduction in the
download sides on average
and 16% reduction in
size on disk on average.
So with this optimization,
the download is smaller,
the install is faster, and
it takes less space on disk.
And this is exactly the
kind of optimizations
we can introduce on your
behalf without asking
you to put any time or effort.
And I guess some of
you might be thinking,
well, if we provide Google Play
our libraries uncompressed,
it might increase the
size of the artifact
we upload to Google.
And some of you might
be worried that it
may push your limit over the
100 megabyte upload limit
we have in the Play Console.
So the good news is that we're
actually changing all the size
logic in the Play
Console to be based
on the compressed download size.
The upload size isn't really
meaningful, especially
not in the world of bundles.
It is not what the
user downloads,
and it's not what
ends on their device.
So starting today, all the size
validations in the Play Console
are based on the
compressed download size.
MILENA NIKOLIC: And
there is one more change
we are making to
the app size limits.
We were very keen
to make life easier
even for developers of large
apps who rely on expansion
files to date.
So I'm happy to announce we
are increasing the download
size for a APKs generated from
the bundle from 100 megabytes
to 500 megabytes.
This means that for apps
up to 500 megabytes,
you can stop using
expansion files entirely.
This doesn't change the size
warning on the Play Store,
but it does mean that
releasing large app
is much easier to manage.
Adobe has been testing
large app bundles with us
with their new video editing
app, Adobe Premiere Rush.
This premium video
editing software
is coming soon to
Android and Chromebooks.
Adobe Premium Rush uses
a lot of native code,
so this means that
for them bundles
saves them quite a lot of disk
space on each individual user
device.
We are inviting
early access partners
to start testing this with us,
so if you're interested, please
reach out to your beta manager.
OK, so to recap that was the
latest for the Android app
bundle and how we are
making your apps smaller
and your releases simpler.
The next big change that
the new app model introduces
is modularization and
dynamic code loading.
This is an approved safe way to
load functionality and features
dynamically making your app
store smaller at install time.
Let me tell you how this works.
Dynamic features
are conceptually
similar to all the other
things we do for our--
for our bundles.
You don't need to send the same
features to 100% of your users
if you know that only
maybe about 10% of them
will be using it.
However, there's
one big difference
between dynamic feature
modularization and resource
modularization, and that is that
feature marginalization doesn't
happen among
predefined binaries.
Basically, you are in
full control around
how you slice out
your app and what
are the things you want
delivered dynamically.
Dynamic features can
be installed on demand
when users request
them, or you can
choose to deferred
installation to a later time,
for example, when app
goes to the background.
On pre-L devices that don't
support dynamic features,
we fuse all these
optionals into the main app
so it's delivered
at the install time.
All of these use cases that I've
just very briefly went through
are currently
supported in production
by some of the largest
apps on the platform
and millions of users have been
benefiting from them already.
Facebook was one of
our launch partners
for this functionality,
and currently they're
using dynamic
features in production
across their entire
app portfolio.
Let's take a look
at their story.
KOBI GLICK: So app size is
really important to Facebook.
When launching
new features, they
evaluate the features
benefit with this size
it actually adds to the app.
Dynamic features allow
them to add functionality
to apps like Facebook
and Facebook Lite
without increasing the size
of the app that install time.
Dynamic features are also
important to their high end
device strategy,
because they can
ship specific advanced features
only to supported devices.
They can also remove
features over time
to save space so the
feature don't stay
for the lifetime of the app.
Facebook told us that dynamic
features work especially well
for new features that
are separate-- logically
separate from the main app.
They can have a separate team of
engineers work on that feature
and they can then
add them to the app
without impacting its
base install size.
Here are some cool examples of
features that are used today
in production by Facebook apps.
One example, for example,
is card scanning.
Card scanning is
the functionality
that is only used by a small
percentage or Facebook user
base.
So by turning this into
a dynamic features,
they avoid shipping almost two
megabytes to every user device.
Another example is real
time communication.
By moving voice in video
chat to a dynamic feature,
they can make sure
these features are only
shipped to devices
that support them
and only to user who
are interested in using
those features.
So this is about
dynamic features.
They make it possible for you to
build highly configurable apps
and, as we've seen,
using production
by some of the biggest
developers on the platform.
Now let's talk about
another type of module.
The Android app bundle
support instant app modules.
So the next section is
all about the first step
in user acquisition journey, and
how we help you with discovery
by helping users try your apps.
MILENA NIKOLIC:
We've been working
on instant apps over
the past two years
and improving it based
on your feedback.
We recently made URLs
optional, and we've added
try now flow on the Play Store.
Google Play Instant is now
on 1.3 billion devices,
and it is highly compelling.
Historically, it used
to be non-trivial effort
for developers to adopt this
because of the independent
build and release process.
Now you don't have to worry
about building and maintaining
your instant apps separately
from your installed app.
As of recently, the Android app
bundle supports instant apps
and makes adoption much easier.
In Android Studio 3.2, you
can build an instant app
with the app bundle format.
This lets you benefit from all
the bundled size optimizations,
which means that you can
get under the instant app
limit much easier.
The requirements general
are pretty simple.
Your instant app module and
your main app entry point module
need to be under 10 megabytes
to enable the Try Now
button in the Play
Store, and you
need to handle
permissions gracefully
like all apps should anyway.
But that's not all.
KOBI GLICK: It's going
to become even easier.
In Android Studio
3.3 beta version,
you can now build and
upload a single artifact
for your instant
and installed app,
We let you upload an artifact
of any size to the Play Console,
and then you can start reducing
the size of the artifact
to meet the 10 megabyte limit.
As we've seen earlier,
using dynamic features
is a key strategy in reducing
the size of your app.
This makes it possible
for many, many more of you
to start offering
instant experiences
for your installed apps.
And developers going down this
road are seeing great success.
Because by offering
a trial, you can
capture many users who would
have otherwise moved on
without installing your app.
Ultimate guitar you
see here told us
that once they launched
your instant app,
they've seen 8% increase
in their install size
and that 20% of users
who click Try Now
ended up installing the app.
So this is about
how we allow you
to now offer instant experiences
using the Android app bundle.
Now let's talk about
the final step in user
acquisition journey,
retaining users over time.
And one of the ways you do
that is by making sure users
use your latest and
greatest app version.
And you know that
Google Play offers
auto updates
functionality and many,
many users have auto update
turned on but not all users.
And in some markets, even though
users have auto updates turned
on, they never actually
connect to Wi-Fi so they
don't get to update their apps.
MILENA NIKOLIC: I'm very happy
to announce that today we're
launching a new API that allows
you to prompt users to update
without ever leaving your app.
You can call this API
to determine if there
is an update available.
And if so, you can show
prompt to users asking
them to accept the update.
In this example,
flow is designed
for immediate critical use
cases like privacy or revenue
affecting bugs.
It's a full screen
experience where
the user is expected to wait
until the download is complete
so that they can, kind of--
they can start using
the new experience.
We make this quite
easy for you to adopt,
because we take care of
all the updating of the app
and the entire lifecycle
related to that.
I think some of you have already
built flows similar to this,
but this is now a
standardized method,
which can be adopted
very, very easily.
However, instead of
an immediate update,
you can also do
a flexible update
with this API,
which doesn't have
to be applied straight away.
This is actually my favorite
part about this API.
You can completely customize
the update experience
so that it really
feels like something
that's part of your app.
For example, you may decide
to very gently nudge users
with an inline flow
like Google Chrome is
doing in this example,
and once the user accepts
the update the download
starts in the background
so users can keep using
your app while the down is
being fetched.
Once the down is complete,
it's basically up to you
to decide when you
want to apply it.
You can do that straight
away and ask user
to restart the app, you
can wait for the app
to go back to background, or
for users to stop using it.
Google Chrome is
testing this now.
We are inviting all of you
to join us in testing this.
Again, reach out to
your beta manager
if you would like to join us.
OK, so to recap
insuring more users
use your latest
release is important.
You can do that by following
some of these best practices
here or by integrating with
our in app updates API.
The API is available
for any app,
so you can get
started with it even
while you're in the process of
switching to the Android app
bundle.
KOBI GLICK: So all the
efforts we showed you today
are all about helping you
drive more installs and fewer
uninstalls, offer
highly configurable apps
through dynamic features, and
keep your users up-to-date.
If you want to come
and chat to us,
we'll be around with a
few folks from our product
and engineering teams.
If you want to share anything
you've heard about today,
this link to the medium post
is a great place to start.
Thank you for listening
and enjoy Playtime.
MILENA NIKOLIC: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]